hello everyone i am sonam pankaj and
today we will be looking into time
series forecasting on univariant data
sets of confirmed cases in corona virus
bit introduction about me
so i'm sonia pankaj working as a
software lead in one of the
startups incubated at iit madras i also
served as an ex-visiting faculty at pes
university
for robotics and computer vision i'm
also a tech speaker for machine learning
and uh this is my first
pi data global talk and i'm so excited
about it
so the content that we will be talking
about today
is first exponential growth in epidemic
uh it's
intuitively difficult for human mind to
understand exponential growth so we will
just take a look into it history of
pandemics so we all know that pandemics
are not new and we will look into the
previous pandemics that uh and outbreaks
uh in the history planning the curve why
social distancing was important why it
was important to wear a mask and
keep the
control keep a control on the
spread of the virus
metrics of prediction so we are using
various algorithms for prediction and
forecasting and to measure the accuracy
we will be using uh
we will be using rmse which will be the
matrix of prediction
uh understanding differences between
prediction and forecasting so often my
friends gets confused between what is
the difference between prediction and
forecasting uh we will be looking at
some basic algorithms like naive moving
average then we will get into machine
learning algorithm but before we get
into machine learning algorithm you'll
have to understand how to do the train
and valid split because it's very
important to uh split your data set into
training and validation to measure the
accuracy uh the machine learning
algorithms we will be following is
linear regression support vector machine
rn the recurrent
uh regret neural network and lstm uh the
other two uh
the other two libraries available for
forecasting our profit and arima
and then we will be comparing the
results and get into multivariate models
now there's a case uh
intuitively explain if if this there if
there's one water lily and it doubles
its population every day how long it
will take to reach about 1 000 lilly
plant
for that one
water lily
think exponentially so here you're into
maybe a
according to intuition it may take one
week
or
maybe one month
two weeks
so the answer is when we see the
exponential growth the answer is 10 days
it's going to take 10 days for that one
leaf plant to go to a population of 1
000
so as i told you the pandemics haven't
been
uh
new
there have been a lot of uh
pandemic cases in the history but the
global corona virus death toll to on on
the 30th of september has reached more
than 1 million and
uh there has been
33.6 million cases that have been
confirmed
and the
um
during the bubonic plague 200 million
deaths were there
smallpox was also considered as a
pandemic before its vaccine was
discovered
so uh and spanish flu killed about 50
million people so we can say uh there
have been uh uh pandemics uh
continuously coming in the human history
so why flattening the curve is important
because if we let the disease one of the
most important factor of coronavirus was
the the rate by which it was spreading
so the rate is uh almost i naught that
is
reproductive rate is almost 2 so if we
allow it to expand it
at its natural
way it will reach this exponential graph
it will reach its uh red
uh
it will go on the red
red path so we do not want that because
it will become very difficult to control
that
we will it will be very difficult for
the medical facilities to provide the
medical facilities
required for that population so uh we
basically have to
bring down the
course of the curve into the logistic
curve and
it doesn't surpass the medical
facilities uh
that we have now available
now we will talk about the metrics of
performance so on what basically we will
decide which algorithm is performing
well
so there could be many metrics there
called error
first
which is like forecast minus actual then
you can use mean square error absolute
error
each having its own formula we are going
to use rmse rmse
or root mean square is a quadratic
scoring rule that also measures the
average magnitude of the error it's the
square root of the average of the square
differences between the prediction and
actual observation
so a lot of people talk about what is
the difference between prediction and
forecasting
so a prediction prediction is basically
uh
till the time you have collected the
data if you are performing prediction on
that data set it is uh
it is prediction but if you want to
perform prediction on the future data
set it
it's forecasting so the only difference
is till you have collected data
if you are predicting uh five steps
beyond that uh point then it will be
called as forecasting
now the forecasting algorithm we will be
using is knife forecasting moving
average machine learning algorithm like
linear regression svm or support vector
machine
lstm which is
long and short-term
don't do much we just take the data and
then put it uh
put it in the future so what's happening
it's it's over fitting the curve so if
if i if i want to write a code of knife
or casting let's just take appending the
data
one step beyond
and if i want to plot the knife it's
it's like this
it's a it's following the same curve as
your actual one so it's actually doing
it's just taking one step uh behind data
and you are putting it in
now if we uh moving on to moving average
series so in moving average series we do
prediction in the uh we find the mean of
all the data collected on that day
and try to predict in the next window
okay
so it's not just taking data uh
to the previous day but it is also
trying to forecast it and find the mean
in the next window in the next in the
future in
okay so moving average now we can see
here there's a window size
that has been implemented
okay
so now if we want to plot the series how
it will look it will look like something
distorted so uh both naive and average
are very basic algorithms uh and they
the nature the trend has been similar
but you can see it it's it's just like a
little distorted curve and there's a lot
of error like five uh of
10 approximately 10 000 differences
so let's talk about uh time and train
and valid set
it's important to take care of the
validation set because of time stress
problem is tricky and we have to take
into account the time component one
cannot directly use the train test split
or k-fold validation since this will
disturb the pattern in the series the
validation set should be created
considering the time uh
date and time values so we will be
creating time
said for our machine learning algorithms
on forecasting of
the data
so
now moving on to machine learning
algorithm so the first machine learning
algorithm that comes in mind is linear
regression
so what is linear regression linear
regression is you're uh
fitting the
fitting the line through maximum number
of points if this is the linear
regression the red line is trying to go
through the maximum number of blue
points here so your theta is your
parameter and x is your data
so how you train a linear regression
order you try to minimize the
mean square error by tweaking your
parameters and
with your data set x and y
training a model means setting its
parameters so that your model fits the
training set
all right now
uh taking the data sets date wise now we
since we are getting into machine
learning we need to make training
machine learning data set and valid
machine learning data set because we
will be training in that uh train to
enable set and we will be validating our
algorithm in the valid ml data set
in linear regression you can easily
import a library called linear
regression and you can uh easily apply
uh
this training ml in the linear
regression
so here linear regression fit your
machine learning date wise and your
training ml confirm cases
while predicting linear regression we
again
import linear regression dot predict
for validate assess on that days
so the graph look like this you can see
it is trying to pass to the maximum
number of points but we can still see
there is a lot of difference
of a number of confirmed cases
from the actual one
now
uh taking to the support vector machine
now support vector machine is also a
classification between a positive and
negative point but it works in the
hyperplane level now what is a
hyperplane is the question to understand
hyperplane we have to go into a little
bit of geometry now what is a line a
line is
a
point with a direction
what is a plane a plane is a line with a
direction so now what is a hyperplane
the hyperplane is a n minus one vector
in n vector spaces so the hyper plane is
having n minus 1 vector directions
that is the first thing so that there
are three steps for svm
first step is you have to maximize the
distance between your hyperplane and
your support vector now what is the
support factor the first point where it
exists
the first data set point the line
crossing that is your support vector so
we have to maximize the distance between
them
the second point is minimize the number
of misclassification distances so apply
a slack variable and minimize the
distance of
misclassification the third point is
if the data is non-linear so you can see
that line cannot differentiate between
positive and negative even plane cannot
differentiate differentiate between
positive and negative but when we
introduce a uh
3d mapping over here if we map all the
data in a 3d plot we can easily
differentiate between positive and
negative
a simple
example could be this
so you can see you cannot differentiate
with the plane but when you increase its
planar ability in the 3d
you can easily differentiate the two
points
so let's see if it improves the accuracy
first we are trying to import mapping
mapping so you will set all the
parameters here in the params vm using
svr
you will call grid search for uh
describing your estimator
and uh your
cross validation
[Music]
now we are trying to fit the training
train ml days and confirm data sets
so you can see here
if you do not want to give some
parameters by yourself it will take its
parameters defaults as well
now if you are trying to predict it's
the best estimator you can go to the
valid ml
data days and then you can just predict
now for the plots so we can see a little
bit of improvement it is following the
trend the accuracy is also very well but
we are not sure that in future that this
uh accuracy will sustain
so i uh so now i want to introduce rnn
so what
and inn is
basically a sequential model of a
special kind of networks so
uh
if you have sentences
and there are words in it so if you want
to understand the inferences of those
words you can use
rnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnlnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
and
yeah so there's a lot of dependencies on
the later data so suppose there are two
sentences beard grylls runs a show and
run away from the beard
so in those two
the bare word has two different meanings
one is animal one is a person so unless
and until you finish the sentence and
you reach to the first stop you cannot
understand that which bear is it
pointing to so we have so iron needs the
whole uh
you know whole sequence of your word to
understand it is largely dependent on
the later data points or what uh coming
up and you can take any length of input
and you can have any length of outputs
here
adding an enable modeling time dependent
and sequential data tasks such as stock
predictions machine translation text
generation however rnn suffers from a
problem called gradient distance which
hampers the learning of a long data
sequences the gradients carry
information used in rnn parameters
update and when the gradient becomes
smaller and smaller the parameters uh
place becomes insanely insignificant
which means there are no real
learning done
so what is happening is
so these are the architecture of
rnn
so you can see there's a inputs
at every cell there's output of every
cell and the activation function is
passing from one cell to another
so i told you about the problem the
neural network this neural network
architecture suffers from a problem of
vanishing gradient that means there is
no
loss left to back back propagate and
learn from the network so there is not
much learning happening in the initial
cells
okay
however rnn suffers from the problem of
vanishing gradient which hampers
learning of long data sequences the
gradient
carry information used in the rnn
parameter update
and when the gradient becomes smaller
and smaller the parameter updates become
insignificant which means there is no
real learning done
all right
so to overcome vanishing gradient we
move to lstm a long short term memory
algorithm
in
the lstm network has three gates that
update and control the cell states these
are the forget kit input kit and your
output gate the
gates use hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid
function to keep
it activated the forget kit controls
what information in the cell state to
forget given the new information that
enter the network the input kit control
what new information will be encoded
into the cell given the new information
so what is happening over here is
there's a learning happening at every
step and there's a memoization memory
which is forgetting some according to
their importance and it is keeping some
and transferring it to the next cell
the output kit controls what information
coded in the cell state is sent to the
network as input in the following the
time step that is done via output vector
okay
so it's pretty easy to code lstm you can
import the keras model kind of
sequential model and you can give two
layers of lstm
and you can give two layers of your
activation function
you can pass on its
parameters like optimizer stochastic
gradient descent you can tell which
optimizer you want
you can tell which metrics you want to
know and you can make a history
model dot fit
on the training data set so how this is
how you
fit the model or train the model on the
data
so now if you want to predict
this is the output of the lstm
okay you can see that it's uh it's
following the trend very well and it's a
kind of very close
to the actual
now we will get into model aroma model
rmf fit or
model dot fit
prediction uh you can just
import a library called stats model
uh erma
from there you can import a r a a r i m
a
and
it occurs in log series you can just fit
the model
and then you can do the prediction in
your valid
set
now if we want to uh plot it it will
look something so you can see we trained
at until this
and then we validated the set on this uh
orange points and the green points are
your prediction so we can see they're
quite close and the rmse value is going
to be quite low in the case of rmr
now profit the profit has been given by
facebook
so you can just import a library for
from fb profit import profit and then
you can
see the confirmed cases you can make the
data a data frame and sip it
date wise and
the confirmed cases and then you you can
take the date twice confirm cases and
your
numbers
and then you can fit the profit and then
you can
forecast
so it looks something like this
you can see
it's quite close
and
the black dots are profit prediction and
the blue ones are the real ones
so now the comparison sheet so we saw
that moving average
was about 42 000
uh and the linear regression was also
didn't quite perform well 35 000. svm is
about 22 000 profit 99700
arima is 4000 and lstms is 10 000.
so we have seen the cases of univariant
models and
in the confirmed cases of coronavirus
now let's understand what is a
multivariate model the multivariate time
series has more than one time dependent
variable each variable depends not only
on the paths values but also some
dependencies on the other variables so
whenever we have uh
different
sets of variables and each are depending
on each other then we can say it's a
multivariate model and
we will see how to solve a multivariate
podcasting now
[Music]
okay
so in multivariate autoregression
uh
in vlr model each variable is a linear
function of its past values
of
of itself and the past values of all the
other variables to explain this it's
better and i'm going to use this example
so
suppose that two
time dependent variables so they're
dependent on their constant values their
coefficients and their
errors but these coefficients are not
only dependent on uh
this
time model but in in
its other time series values as well so
you can see how we can incorporate
using vector auto regression model
thank you everyone uh for joining me
in case you need the code it is
available on my youtube account you can
follow me on twitter pankaj sonam and if
you have any queries you can contact me
directly through my email id thank you
so much
thank you so much it has been a pleasure